we know that uh russian troops have been
stretching the ukrainian defenses with a
multi-pronged attack
the british ministry of defense defense
information in the mod have produced
some estimates of where they think the
forces are and they confirm more or less
what we've been saying that forces in
crimea have moved north and and
eastwards that forces from belarus have
moved towards kiev and are in the north
of kiev but forces up in the northwest
have not done as well and seem to have
been held
particularly at a place like chernov it
doesn't appear that they've got through
that very easily and so some of these
forces are more slow arriving in kiev
than they expected to be let's just have
a look at what's happening in the
donbass the donbass region is where all
this started what in a sense
this was supposed to be all about and as
expected russian forces have moved out
of crimea and were expected to move from
the donbass region itself to actually
link up
it doesn't look as if they've made it
because ukrainian forces seem to be
holding them even though they're caught
in some something of a pincer in the
donbass region but it looks as if some
of the fighting there has been fairly
fierce and at least from an immediate
perspective has actually helped the
ukrainians but of course the big issue
is kiev what is happening in kiev let's
just have a look at the satellite
photograph
in kiev we know that russian forces have
effectively arrived in the northern part
of the city they are in the oblong
district of the on the edge of it and
one would expect them to be able to move
in if they wanted to we also know that
russian forces have arrived in the west
of the city there is no sign yet that
russian forces have made it in similar
situations in the east or the south of
the city maybe because they haven't been
able to get there as quickly as was
expected we also know that there have
been um fights at the hospital airfield
and some
conflict at the boris bill airport
the fact is that
kiev in a sense is like a clock at ten
o'clock uh at twelve o'clock ten o'clock
at nine o'clock the russians know that
their forces are there they're waiting
to complete the circle and when kiev is
encircled then they have the choice as
to what to do next and whether to
actually tell the ukrainian government
just to go or to move in and remove them